hi everyone how are you doing my name is
Elizabeth yen and I've been a startup
founder and now I'm a startup investor
and because of this a lot of people
often ask me well how did you know that
you are passionate about startups or
startup investing and the truth is I
didn't or I don't you know everybody is
trying to find their passion these days
but passion you know I think you
can you can go your whole life and
search for what you're passionate about
and just never find it so tonight this
happened anybody so tonight I'm gonna
tell you about the guiding light that I
use for my own career and it's really
simple it's this I like to jump into
fascinating adventures or work with
amazing people that's it or ideally both
so I'm gonna share with you three
stories the first is how I actually
decided to start my company launch bit
and that was entirely about working with
amazing people and in fact actually it
started a long time ago back in high
school so in ninth grade my best friend
Jennifer one day she came to me and she
said hey my cousin Tony is starting a
company do you want to help him out
during winter break I had no idea what a
startup was but I didn't have anything
going on during winter break and the
opportunity to work with Jennifer and
her cousin and all these other people
seemed really cool so we came up to San
Francisco went to his office and it was
a really amazing experience we did not
help with anything we were worried were
useless but just observing everything
was amazing here was her cousin Tony he
was working with his friends and they
were building things and they could eat
all the pizza in the world it was the
dream
so on that day I decided that that was
what I wanted to do when I grew up I
wanted to build things with my closest
friends and actually you know Jennifer
and I made a pact in high school that we
would start a company together someday
now on that day I was really naive I had
no idea how startups make money or any
of that in fact actually it wasn't until
two years later that I realized what
would happen next when her cousin Tony
actually sold that company to Microsoft
for what was reported a couple hundred
million dollars and then later he went
to bet on another company another
startup which he now runs a day a small
little shoe company you may know called
Zappos so I did not know though on that
day that that you know that is one way
to make money all I knew was I just
wanted to work with my friends so years
later in 2010 Jennifer and I teamed up
and we started launch bit and over the
next few years we grew it we eventually
sold it to a larger company on the East
Coast and really what drove me to do
that startup it was all about working
with amazing people the second story
that I want to share is about having an
adventure so my senior year of college I
got in my head that I wanted to go to
business school and the fall that year I
was applying to business schools as a
senior in college and I really wanted to
visit a couple of the schools that I was
applying to that were in Boston but I
was here on the west coast I didn't want
to pay for my plane ticket to go to
Boston so I decided that somebody else
would pay for this ticket for me
fortunately there was actually a
competition of some sort where the prize
was a free trip to Boston just
coincidentally it was just right there
around that time and I entered the
contest and I won and so I got my free
trip to Boston and this competition was
sponsored by a job fair
it turns out that that job fair was the
largest job fair for jobs in Japan I
don't know why they hold it in Boston
every year but they do and in order to
get my reimbursement for the plane
ticket I had to go to the job fair as it
would turn out I did not get into any
business school that year but I ended up
getting a job on the spot at the job
fair so I you know I was kind of
conflicted about what to do but it's not
a really amazing to be able to work in
Tokyo this is not something I had
planned and so I took the job the next
fall I moved to Tokyo and a month into
the job my boss pulled me aside and he
said Elizabeth this really is not
working out your Japanese is not good
enough for this job and I was just like
oh my god am I getting fired from my
first job here and fortunately they were
really nice about it they said okay you
can't stay in this job but we're gonna
move you into the marketing department
where you will not have to talk with
customers so that's how I ended up
getting into marketing and but they said
that actually they didn't have enough
budget for me to stick around for very
long so I ended up trying to figure out
what I wanted to do next around that
time and since it was the fall again I
decided to reapply to business school
this time I only had enough time to
apply to one school and I actually
really didn't have time to rewrite any
essay so I sent in the same ones
unfortunately the questions were the
same and I sent in the same letters of
recommendation and I didn't have time to
take the test again so I sent in
everything pretty much the same and this
time I got in
my takeaway from that is I couldn't get
into business school so I got this job
and I couldn't keep the job so I got
into business school and the the overall
lesson that I learned though is that you
just never really know how failure and
success will be coupled together you
just when you do one of these adventures
and you jump in you can't really see the
end result but somehow everything will
just sort of all work itself out and you
should just go for it anyway
even if you don't think you're qualified
enough to speak enough Japanese for a
job or what not the last story that I
have to share is about how I got into
startup investing so I actually had
never ever thought about becoming either
a venture capitalist or nor had thought
about getting into startup investing and
the the short story is after jennifer
and I sold launch bit eventually I made
my way back to 500 startups which is
where launch bit had been incubated a
few years before and I went there
because again I either really like
working with amazing people or jumping
into adventures and there were a number
of amazing people whom I wanted to work
with there and what I noticed in the
process of getting into investing I had
the opportunity to work with hundreds of
teams that went through our accelerator
program and so I saw a lot of teams and
how they executed and I'm sure many of
you already know this somewhat
intuitively but having actually seen a
lot of the data
what really floored me was this founders
who fit a certain profile like their
pedigree or the way they look or the way
they talk if they check all the boxes
it's really easy for them to raise money
but if they don't and the in even if
these founders execute really well it is
very difficult for them to raise money
now this may sound somewhat obvious or
intuitive to many of you if you are
startup founder
you've shared this sort of experience
but I've actually seen it firsthand with
hundreds of startups and so along the
way about a year ago my friend Eric bond
and I started batting around this idea
of can we change this
can we bring about a meritocracy to at
least early-stage startup investing or
at least work in that direction and so
we decided that the best way to try to
tackle this problem is to start a new VC
fund we had no intention ever of
becoming venture capitalists but this
was the vehicle for doing so
and this is where I am today in my
career journey this is yet another
adventure that I am jumping into one
that is very meaningful to me and also
fortunately I also have the opportunity
to work with amazing people such as Eric
such as many of our collaborators and
founders and investors and I don't know
where it will lead but it is going to be
another amazing journey now
if I look at my own resume and I see ok
I was at a tech company and then I
became a start-up founder and then now
an investor it almost seems like oh that
was very intentional but in actuality at
each of these steps
it was very fuzzy the whole way through
I never knew what was going to happen at
the end of each journey but that's ok
because even though that was fuzzy one
thing that was very clear to me at each
point in time was that I knew that by
jumping into either an adventure or
working with amazing founders I would
learn a lot and I would grow a lot and
so I encourage all of you as you look at
your own careers to kind of think about
it in this lens can you jump into an
amazing adventure can you work with
amazing people rather than looking from
the perspective of am i passionate about
this or am I going to be able to climb
up this ladder because ultimately by
jumping into amazing journeys or working
with amazing people you will find a lot
of personal growth and ultimately that's
what people value in their careers thank
you
[Applause]